good morning Hank it's Sunday on Tuesday
I'm going to announce your punishment
and discuss the political situation in
Pakistan but today we discuss a matter
of pressing international importance the
Twilight Saga so Hank before I begin
discussing Twilight I have to give the
guys in nerdfighteria all 42 of you a
brief summary of the series ok so
there's a new girl in school and boy
does her blood smell good
which of course would be irrelevant to
most of us but most of us aren't Edward
Cullen hot hot hot vampire Edward Cullen
looks like he's 17 but he's 107 years
old and he's a vampire so he's dangerous
but he's also very chivalrous because he
comes from the old school because he's
107 years old and he's beautiful in his
eyes change color he's got super sexy
puffs also he sparkles when he's in the
sunshine and apparently this is what
girls want us to be is sparkly non
farting 107 year olds in seventeen year
old bodies so anyway then this 107 year
old gets in a relationship with a 16
year old girl which for some reason
isn't wrong now make before I talk about
how much I love Twilight I want to
explain why it's wrong for adults to
have romantic relationships with
teenagers it's not because we look old
it's because we are old it's not a
question of the youngness and chiseled
nosov your pecs it's a question of how
many times you've been around the Sun
also in the Twilight books this girl
Bella really needs dudes to take care of
her because she is like completely crazy
without them and you almost get the
feeling from reading the books that like
a woman can't be whole until she has a
strong independent man in her life to
take care of her when of course the fact
is that a woman needs a strong man to
take care of her like a fish needs a
bicycle I mean just us the Yeti hey
Sarah do you need a man who can bench
press your body weight in order to feel
whole obviously not and that's not cuz
she's a big girl either all that said
now and again a fantasy world comes
along that is so engrossing and exciting
and intoxicating that you never even
stop to think like isn't it a little bit
you know criminal for 107 year olds to
have relationships with 16 year old
girls and for me and millions of others
such as the case with Twilight you just
want to keep turning the pages because
while you're reading the books nothing
matter
is more to you than the question of
whether or not they will finally you
know do it there I said it
and yes I think Edward and Bella's
relationship dynamics are troubling and
that you shouldn't conflate obsession
with love but we all romanticize the
people we adore particularly in high
school and Edward Cullen and Jacob black
are both really well idealized romantic
others and by well idealized romantic
others I of course mean that they are
hot so Hank I just saw New Moon the
movie and to be honest I thought it was
kind of stupid but it reminded me of
what I really do like about Twilight
it's fun it distracts me from the pain
and brokenness of the world and it
argues that true love will triumph in
the end which may or may not be true but
if it's a lie it's the most beautiful
lie we have that's why I think the
question of whether Harry Potter or
Twilight is better is as the Buddhists
would say a question wrongly asked as
series I don't think they're after the
same goals and I'd like to think that we
could read broadly enough to live in a
world that includes both of them and
more you know like my books so Hank
that's my review I think the books are
insanely fun to read I thought the movie
was pretty stupid although Jacob Black
is insanely v-shaped in his torso
I'm sure the conversation will continue
in comments nerdfighters don't forget to
be awesome Hank I will punish you on
Tuesday
and yes Hank because I'm discussing
Twilight today I left a button
unbuttoned